we begin with breaking news tonight now
we have good news and bad news out of
the biden white house all right first
the good news the most pompous and
dishonest press secretary in american
history she will be gone at the end of
the week the bad news her replacement is
a full-blown tinfoil hat conspiracy
theorist who thinks that many of her
political opponents are racist and we've
got a full hand of the investigation
into karine jean-pierre coming up but we
begin tonight with this the big guy joe
biden his genius new plan to battle
inflation take a look
and i agree with what chairman powell
said last week that the number one
threat is the strength
in that strength that we built is
inflation look
i know you got to be frustrated
i know
i can taste it
translation in this country do you take
any responsibility of your policies i
think our policies help not hurt
think about what they say
the vast majority of the
of the uh uh
of the economist
think that this is going to be a real
tough problem to solve but it's not
because of spending
i'm screaming at the tv how have they
helped joe now since joe has clearly
lost any ability to communicate because
of his cognitive decline allow me to try
to translate for him there's no plan to
curb inflation by the way it's not
transitory either there's no plan to
lower gas prices there's no plan to spur
on economic growth or as bloomberg
reported quote inside the administration
there is a sense of frustration doom and
some say magical thinking about
inflation
magical thinking we're now on the verge
of what is a devastating recession
coupled with record-setting inflation
and of course on top of that a supply
chain crisis and gas prices yep they
just hit a brand new record high along
with diesel prices now the stock market
is plunging right before our eyes
fortunes i mean fortunes are being lost
by the middle class in this country and
people on fixed incomes in this country
country that means their pensions
retirement funds 401ks they're getting
wrecked on in the market there's a
nationwide shortage of baby formula and
the white house is thinking about the
economy in a magical way well it's time
for heads to roll joe's economic and
energy policies they're nothing but a
complete and utter disaster biden's
inflation is now costing you the average
american the average american household
over five thousand two hundred dollars
annually and new numbers out today show
the average american is paying two
thousand dollars more per year just for
gasoline but nothing is going to change
because the democratic party is ruled by
socialists that are all part of this
religious climate alarmist cult and they
will never retreat from their radical
agenda i don't see that ever happening
they don't seem to care if you the
american people suffer they don't care
if the country implodes so long as the
system is fundamentally transformed the
way they want and capitalism becomes a
thing of the past and according to them
we all must pay for our sins against
mother earth and beg iran and venezuela
and opec to produce the oil we could be
producing ourselves so no matter how
high gas prices go biden's not going to
open up drilling and fracking he's not
going to greenlight the keystone xl
pipeline the alberta premier said we'd
be getting 900 000 barrels of canadian
oil a day had he let that continue to be
finished by now and no matter how bad
inflation gets joe's not going to stop
spending either as the economy gets
worse and worse the administration they
keep peddling more dumb excuses one
after another you know the usual biden
excuse uh for example treasury secretary
janet yellen she was supposed to be a
brilliant economic mind as it turns out
janet has lost all touch with reality
she now wants you to believe that a
future supreme court ruling on roe v
wade is the cause of joe biden's
economic and energy policies and all the
problems we had
i thought this was all caused by putin
and donald trump i guess i was wrong
if
the draft of the court's majority
holding in roe versus way
is the actual decision what impact will
the loss of abortion access mean
economically for women
well i believe that eliminating the
right of women to make decisions
about when and whether to have children
would have very damaging effects
on the economy and would set women back
decades
there won't be a loss of abortion access
there might be restrictions in some
states but there's going to be plenty of
opportunities for everyone that wants
one now remember this is the same janet
yellen that promised inflation was
transitory janet was wrong inflation is
not transitory our economy is a train
wreck and yet janet yellen continues to
toe the party line at this point she
really is nothing more than a useful
idiot and it's past time that she sell
off into retirement hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else